hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast large scale purification
of RNA and RNA based nanoparticles by
prepara Tavoris interrogation i am dr.
chad schwartz senior application
scientist at beckman coulter and i'll be
your moderator for today's event we have
delighted to bring you this educational
webinar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by beckman coulter beckman
coulter is a leader in centrifugation
and flow cytometry and has long been an
innovator and particle characterization
lab automation and genomics that can
culture products are used at the
forefront of important areas of
investigation discovery for more
information please visit please visit
but beckman coulter com we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the icon in the lower right hand corner
the slide window if you have any
technical problems viewing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problems through the green Q&A button I
would now like to introduce today's
speaker Daniel jasinski after completion
of a bachelor's degree in chemistry from
Texas A&M University in 2008 Daniel
decided to pursue his interest in
research in the department of
pharmaceutical sciences at the
university of kentucky's college of
pharmacy he doing the laboratory of dr.
page one glow in the fall of 2012
coincidentally also my former PhD
advisor a world-renowned investigator in
the area area of bio nanotechnology the
glow lab has pioneered the emerging
field of RNA nanotechnology even hosting
a new Gordon research conference in 2015
dedicated to advancing this fast-growing
field Daniels research interests focus
on the construction and manipulation of
nanoparticles composed mainly of RNA
publishing in several high impact
journals the clinical translation of RNA
nanotechnology
is hindered by the amounts of purified
material needed for treatment confront
it with this problem Daniel spent time
developing approaches for the
large-scale production and purification
of RNA nanoparticles especially
ultracentrifugation which acted to
retain the integrity and function of the
nanostructures before we get started
there are a few poll questions that I
would like to ask our audience our first
question is do you have hands on
experience with nanoparticle
purification it's a yes or no question
you can click on the button in the gray
pull a square in front of you will take
about 10 seconds and then we will
disseminate the results it looks like
eighty-three percent of you do not have
any experience with nanoparticle
purification this presentation will also
be about RNA purification so we will
talk about that as well so not a problem
the next question relating to RNA
purification is which method do you most
commonly use is it electrophoresis a lot
of people use page gels chromatography
size exclusion or ion exchange
ultracentrifugation which is today's
topic organic to extraction or I have
never purified RNA
just a few more moments it looks like
43-percent have never purified RNA
twenty-eight percent use organic
extraction 17.9 percent use
electrophoresis seven percent at
chromatography and three percent at
ultracentrifugation so we can definitely
present our results of ultra invitation
here and hopefully ski you in that
direction our third and final question
what are your major concerns when
considering different purification
techniques and this one you can select
all that apply purity yield time
resources retention of function they're
all very important concerns to select
some of the ones that are most important
to you
majority of folks and attendants are
concerned with the purity at
thirty-eight percent twenty-seven
percent are interested in the yield time
and resources comes in at 18 point two
percent and retention a function at
sixteen point seven percent so with that
I would like to thank everyone for their
answers and I will now turn it over to
Daniel jasinski for his presentation hi
chad arm thank you for the nice and
seduction and i appreciate those
questions it comes me some feedback on
the kind of audience that is watching
today um first I would like to thank
Chad and I would also like to thank
Beckman for giving me this opportunity
to talk to you all about today about
some of the work I've done in dr. Bohr's
lab here at the University of Kentucky
on a large fuel large-scale purification
of RNA and RNA based nanoparticles using
ultracentrifugation um like Chad said I
amania I'm just now starting my fourth
year as a graduate student here at the
University of Kentucky so I really
appreciate the opportunity to have a
broader audience to talk about what I've
been doing so first I will be I'm gonna
give you guys a kind of a brief outline
on what I'll be talking to you about um
initially I'm going to start with some
background on RNA or it seems like
people do have some background with RNA
better watching now but I just want to
give an overview for those of you that
don't know too much about RNA and then I
will go into some of the current
technologies that are used to purify RNA
or maybe some issues with in my opinion
some issues of those technologies and
how we can improve them by using ultra
centrifugation then I'll talk a little
bit about the different methods of ultra
centrifugation
um and then I will go into talking about
some RNA nanoparticle background which
is mostly my expertise so I can give you
some rash now on why we need these
methods for RNA purification and for
nanoparticle purification almond and
finally I will move in to some methods
on how from I'll move on to some methods
and give you guys an example of
purifying some RNA after in vitro
transcription and then purifying a
nanoparticle after assembling that
nanoparticle um so now just some
applications of ultracentrifugation
ultrason segregation has very wide
applications in many labs especially
those that do molecular biology
biochemistry and cell biology
ultracentrifugation can be broken down
into two different areas analytical
ultracentrifugation and prepara tip
altra centrifugation and analytical
ultracentrifugation is used mainly to
actually study nor molecule whether that
be molecular interactions such as RNA
protein interactions you can also study
the physical properties of the particles
such as molecular weight its shape and
confirmation and using all this you can
you can determine its sedimentation
coefficient which also relates to the
molecular weight and its shape and
confirmation um but the ultra since
creation method I will be focusing on
and in my and in this webinar today is
prepara to bolt remediation mainly
isolating and purifying specific
particles in this case that particle
will be RNA so what is RNA RNA can be
described as the carrier of information
is so the central dogma of molecular
biology is DNA to RNA to protein RNA
translate translates the genetic
information in DNA to protein for those
and then those proteins carry out there
rolls whatever they may be on note that
all the the RNA or the DNA in the genome
is transcribed into RNA and the
messenger RNA all cinemas mrna is what
actually trans codes for proteins
however not all of the DNA genome codes
for mrna about more than ninety eight
point five percent of the DNA genome is
actually not coded into it into it's
actually not transcribed into RNA that
codes for proteins it's transcribed into
non-coding RNAs also for short ncrnas
these ncrnas they display various
functions throughout the cell including
gene regulation such as a mi RNA this
can cause different it can do different
processes and so those two different
processing and you can upregulate wrote
down regulate the transcription or the
rather the translation of certain
proteins um you can also act as
catalytic RNA such as Robin Symes which
perform kincora actually very similar to
that of proteins and it's involved in
many other cell cellular and biological
processes in the cell and I'll give a
little more detail on that later um so
what does RNA look like the structure of
RNA is very similar to that of DNA it is
made up of it's a polymer made up a four
different bases at a mean you're so
cytosine and guanine are actually a typo
on my side but anyways the structure is
very similar to that of DNA where it's
there's a phosphate bottom backbone
linking the right or sugars at the five
the five and three prime carbons and
then off of the one prime carbon is your
face that's where the ACG new are
located on one major difference between
RNA and DNA is at the two prime position
in RNA there is a 2 prime hydroxyl group
whereas in DNA there's a
there is no adoption group it's just two
hydrogen's off of that to prime position
so this two prime I'm Troxel is a lot of
what gives RNA some of its functionality
and its really its flexibility but at
the same time it also makes on a very
susceptible to X new places and in the
new places in cell which can use this to
prime hydroxyl to attack the phosphate
backbone and electric leave your RNA so
this has kind of hindered rnase use in
vivo due to its knees of degradation
it's very susceptible this unmodified on
it however much research has been done
to overcome this process including some
work in my lab and dr. page members lab
to help overcome this instability of RNA
so that can be used as an EVO
therapeutic one major modification that
can be made to this RNA is a 2 is a 2
prime for ian substitution on the
primitive so on see in the you you
replace the two prime hydroxyl with a
fluorine and this renders your on a more
chemically stable remember dynamically
stable and more importantly
enzymatically stable service Q prime F
we call it to prime F modification
actually decreases its susceptibility to
degradation many places and so so
because of this over the past five to
ten years RNA has garnered great tension
as far as from therapeutics where the BS
RNA or targeting molecules nice things
such as on a AB summers you can select a
random RNA sequence for a specific
protein and it will target that cell and
because of the to permit for
multiplication it can be used in vivo to
target specific cell receptors and
therefore target different tumors and
cancers um so RNA there's also besides
but in Beaver work in therapeutic work
which is what our lab here works on
lots of people on study on a structure
the RNA function in relation to its
structure on RNA has very diverse
structure in folding and many studies on
RNA have elucidated various functions of
on such as a transfer RNA which decodes
the mRNA to amino acids messenger RNA
which contains the code for proteins
ribosomal RNA which is part of the
ribosome and is essential to protein
synthesis on ribozymes which are Caddo
Lake rnase similar to that of proteins
they perform certain chemical reactions
in the cell and then riboswitches is
another one and these are actually you
can be part of an mi a sequence in their
regulatory RNAs so a small molecule will
bind to these riboswitches and they can
can cause it to enhance the production
of protein from certain MRI or it can
cause it to down regulate the production
of protein from a certain and iming so
because of these various functions and
the huge diversity in RNA structure and
function many efforts are being put
towards the sequence based structure
prediction however in most cases means
structural predictions are not perfect
so until they become perfect what lab
experiments need to be need to confirm
these predictions and a lot of this is
done by sa such as NMR or
crystallization and techniques like this
require huge amounts of RNA milligram
amounts which may not sound like huge
amounts but for RNA that's quite a bit
so because of that we definitely need
enhanced ways to create large amounts of
RNA so that we can enhance the field of
RNA research from so like I said earlier
RNA can also be used as a therapeutic in
the cell there's the special double
stranded RNAs arm which are process
and by a protein called I sir and this
dieser cleaves the specific strands into
short double strand RNA is called SI
RNAs in these SI RNAs bind to other
protein complex called a RISC complex
and this risk complex is then guided to
in my Emma RNA by this specific SI RNA
sequence and then this causes cleavage
of the target mrna so cleavage of the
target mi-8 means no protein production
so as opposed to certain small molecule
drugs that are maybe target the protein
specifically to stop its production srna
works a step above that and tries to
just stop protein production completely
from the srna has shown much promise
over the last year's or the last couple
years in this scene has next generation
of drug discovery because theoretically
on every mrna could be a target for this
assign so on a lot of the work in my lab
focuses on using this srna in in vitro
model systems and also in in vivo models
as mice specifically me use this srna to
knock down the production of certain
proteins and because this is on a we
retain a quite big advantage by using
RNA based nanoparticles it's easy for us
to incorporate these RNAs directly into
a male partner so that gives us a huge
reason to develop these large-scale
production techniques for RNA and not a
nap articles so how is RNA mate I would
say the most one most common methods is
using a transcription machinery that
it's like isolated from core I for
example the t7 RNA polymerase another
popular method bond we also use in our
lab is using a chemical synthesis it's
the same method use as DNA consensus
this also yields large amounts of our
name
however the the length of chemical
synthesis is limited to about 60
nucleotides just based on the coupling
efficiency of the phosphor and abide
chemistry with on it so for longer RNA
transcripts enzymatic synthesis is
definitely the most efficient process
however after the in vitro synthesis
you're not only left with your target in
our your target RNA strand you are left
with your proteins the electives in
tepees that do not get incorporated into
the RNA and then also left with your DNA
template so these only to be removed
from the transcription mixture before
the RNA can be used um so some current
technologies and as a lot of you know
because you all answer the poor
questions and all three of these are on
there except release predation on the
there's Joe electrophoresis hplc and
fplc and organic extraction these
methods definitely do have their limits
I've worked with Paige shelves now from
my entire time here and sometimes a page
shells are limited by what we can do
with them for example they're not very
scalable if you want to do a very large
scale transcription you just in most
cases have to increase the mound Jose
you run so that's just more work and
more time and then there's also no also
multiple work up steps arm you know you
have to cut the gel out you have to cut
up the jello pieces and you have to do
an illusion step and a lot of times the
aleutian from the gel is not great so
yield firm transcription may be good but
the you'll need it from your page gels
is not very good now you can increase
your yield funding the gel extraction by
pushing up your gel piece is very small
um but then you're left with
contamination from these gel pieces
after you extract them from the gel so
that that can cause some
definitely can cause some issues when
getting Studies on the army now hplc
it's it's a very good method especially
for modified ala goes from like a
chemical synthesizer with a four or four
works very well to purify large amounts
of that but for on after transcription
the resolution is very limited and then
if you want to purify actual
nanoparticles hplc e or f plc it's not
that great for these large particles a
lot of the particles we make as you will
see later are branched there on a itself
is pretty flexible so it can adopt
multiple confirmations so this will
affect it solution time off of the
column and you'll end up with a low
yield because you miss out on your
fraction collection or you will get a
impure product which is a big concern
when we're trying to get reproducible
results results especially in vivo and
there's also organic extraction which is
used quite commonly however i believe
it's quite easy to get solvent
contamination and then your sample can
also get degraded which well it does
decrease your meal that also introduces
impurity in your sample so why would we
use ultracentrifugation to purify
ironing ultracentrifugation has lots of
advantages over some of these other
methods very efficient sample recovery
there's no extraction step you simply
after you freshen eight your if you
fraction at your gradient all you do is
do some type of dialysis or ethanol
precipitation to remove your salts
there's multiple methods of separation
and can do as I'll show you on the next
slide I think there's multiple types of
gradients you can use so it's widespread
applicability you can do large-scale
preparation the method I outline in this
webinar uses five milliliter tubes but
this is a very scalable method you can
definitely scale it up to larger
tubes it's contamination free as long as
you you know work to prevent any
degradation of your natural RNA then
it's very it's relatively easy to keep
contamination free and then also your
are unable to retain its biological
activity because most of this is just
carried out in different salt solutions
and RNA is very stable and much salt um
so this is just a slide showing some
basic ultra centrifugation concepts
there's three main types of repetative
ultracentrifugation used there's
differential which is pelleting so this
is very similar to doing an ethanol
precipitation and then just spinning
down your RNA or DNA sample to the
bottom so the way that works is it
fraction eights according to shape and
size it's used a lot for the separation
enrichment of organelles and cells or
organelle cells or proteins from like a
whole cell sample like after you would
like to sell you would spin down cells
and it's used lots of that kind of stuff
um then there's equilibrium density
gradients this is used to separate
particles by their density which works
very well for RNA because it's very much
more dense than proteins in even more
than DNA so after you do it in vitro
transcription all you do is load your
sample in and then because of rnase high
density that will separate to the bottom
and you can get a peer product so this
actually works by you put your sample in
and then as you spin as you centrifuge
your sample the gradient forms and your
particles mind great based on their
density and then the last one I will
talk about is a great zonal
ultracentrifugation so this uh this is
kind of similar to the principle of a
gel it's the same type of thing where
the particles flow continuously in this
rate zonal grain
and then they bait they separated based
on their sedimentation rate so larger
particles will set am it faster than
smaller particles so you will be able to
separate your particles based on size
that works very well for the RNA
nanoparticles because in our case we're
when we make a nanoparticle it's a
mixture of multiple single strands then
they form a specific size and shape to
nanoparticle and then we put them in
this gradient and they are able to
separate based on size and me basically
we separate our unanue monomer strands
from our form to nanoparticles so now
I'm going to talk a little bit about
choosing the correct gradient it's
relatively important and this is
comparable one of the most difficult
parts of the ultracentrifugation process
is choosing the gradient you're going to
use when first you need to decide what
kind of salt solid and communities the
solute needs to be inert to your sample
and most have no interaction with your
sample or else that could cause
degradation or it could change its
sedimentation rate based on these
interactions and you wouldn't know that
until after you did it you need to
choose the correct buffer conditions for
example RNA like ice discussed earlier
is susceptible to degradation by rnases
the new places however these nucleases
are divalent metal ion dependent so
whenever we do this we we do this in a
te buffer a buffer that contains EDTA so
it will chelate these divalent metal
ions and prevent the degradation of your
on it and then also it's it's kind of
goes throughout this entire presentation
is it's very important to you sterilize
and autoclaved for agents in our lab we
always autoclave all of our tips are
tubes are buffers it just you need to do
that to make sure you prevent
degradation of your san
is also another important part is that
this your cell you needs to be easily
removed from your sample you don't want
to use a solid you that you don't think
you're going to be able to separate from
your sample because then you'll your
sample will have that for its entirety
then it might be useless depending on
what you're trying to do with your
sample and the next important thing this
applies more to rate zonal is on the
your gradient choice so the way the rate
zonal works is you should always choose
a density of your sucrose solution which
is what we use for the rate zone
ultracentrifugation you should always
use a density that is less dense than
your particle on that way you know
particles never stopped because if your
particles stop at a certain density they
were all aggregate together and then
your leftover with an unfair fight
sample so you're back to a start so a
lot of times on optimization will be
required for the green ink you will need
to use so depending on your method of
detection whether the absorbance
fluorescents maybe some tritium label so
you can use the radioactive signal you
can always start with a small scale and
you can run six samples at a time in the
SW 55 rotor from beckman so you can try
different gradients and optimize your
conditions first and then load your
entire sample for New World purify so
that way you know you end up with the
pure sample so now I'm going to move on
and talk about um my area of expertise
which would be RNA nanotechnology so RNA
nanotechnology was first the proof of
concept was first done back in nineteen
ninety eight when my advisor dr. patient
whoa re-engineered the hexameric RNA in
from the
bacteriophage 529 DNA packaging murder
so from then on until now the lab has
worked very diligently to you know
translate these nanoparticles to where
we can use them in vivo and make them
stable and make them useful so so now we
have constructed therapeutic RNA nano
particles that are chemically stable
some of thine amicus table and that also
display favorable pharmacological
profiles in other words when we inject
them then nice they accumulate in the
tumor without on any detectable toxicity
in the healthy organs so this is the
bacteriophage 529 DNA packaging order
you can see on the diagram on the left
the packaging murder is made up of a pro
capsid which is a protein shell it's
made up also of a conectar protein which
serves as the portal protein for the
double-stranded DNA the dsdna to go
through and in below the are connected
to the connector protein is a the p RNA
molecules which actually help to gear
the packaging of the DNA so the diagram
on the right is the secondary structure
and sequence of this p RNA molecule you
can see that the this p RNA molecule has
some unique structural features
including loops and some bulges so the
ones we exploit and used to make
nanoparticles are the right-hand loop at
the top and your left-hand loop you can
also use the foot down here to fabricate
different nanoparticles also outlined in
red is the three way junction core this
theory attention has been shown to be
exceptionally from dynamically stable
chemically stable we used it in Beaver
it's we found it to be the most stable
natural food way junction out there
compared to any other ones including
like 5s RNA and the Entune bacteriophage
three-way junction
so basically we've taken advantage or
what happens to be very stable through a
junction motif and we used it as an in
vivo drug delivery vehicle um so it's
it's shown to be very successful so
that's kind of the direction we're
headed right now but some other work in
the lab uses these packaging RNA which
is P RNA molecules to construct these
different nanoparticles and one of our
postdocs in the lab put in a lot of work
to develop these three toolkits to
construct these p RNA nanoparticles so
the toolkit one is what she calls
hand-in-hand interaction in other words
you exploit these right hand and left
hand luke that I just talked about on
the previous slide and you exploit them
to create these different shaped
nanoparticles um or not different shaped
but different particles based on these
pra and we do that by increasing this
naturally the PR name has a foreign
includes high boot however we can
artificially increase its stability by
extending these loop 270 nucleotide
overlap so that just gives it more base
pairing and enhances the stability of
these particles so the second tool kit
is what she calls foot to foot
interaction in other words you link
these two p RNA molecules together by
complementary sticking ends and the
third one is what she calls branch
extension arm so that's like I mentioned
earlier using this 30 junction particle
to extend offer helix one and he looks
to and he looks three extending it to
create different nanoparticles and as
you can see we also have this X way
motif which was actually developed by
one of my collaborators for this present
this webinar the data in this webinar
Farzin harm um so here are some
nanoparticles that have been made using
these three toolkits and me we have some
great
liberators at the University of Nebraska
Medical Center that of the college
pharmacy that have helped us to get
these great afm images of all these we
really really cool looking RNA
nanoparticles so you can see in the top
bracketed by hand in haines interactions
we can make trainers tetra myers Penton
marries hexamers heptamer all just based
on on base pairing of these loops that I
just showed you guys and then using the
foot to foot interaction you can extend
the complex you can even more and make
these foot to foot trimers so you're
using your you're combining foot to foot
and hand to hand to make these diverse
shaped nanoparticles and what basically
what this does for us is this gives us
the poly valency and we can attach
multiple functional groups to each of
these particles for example the PRN a
chimera that was featured in human gene
therapy in 2005 this was kind of a very
beginning of the therapeutic research in
the lab so you can use these P RNAs and
you can attach different things such as
RNA optimus s RNA rather x mi RNA and
detection and detection molecules and
chemical writing groups and then you
take each of these P RNAs through the
toolkit interactions and you can create
these multi vein of nanoparticles that
perform multiple functions in the cell
another arm another route to engineering
nanoparticles one that I was heavily in
fall team is using this three-way
Junction nanoparticle of the 30 Junction
motif itself and using what's what we
term as RNA biomimetics and using this
theory junction to construct these
different shape to nanoparticles so here
if for example if you work at the
triangular nanoparticle we actually use
molecular modeling and constructed this
triangle from 3p on a three-way
junctions and then we extend that even
more just by simply adding an additional
strand of
then we can make a square and
interparticle using four three junctions
and then we can also make a pentagonal
shape nanoparticle using 5 privet
junctions I mean we have the afm images
and we see very distinct and compact
nanoparticles and our dynamic light
scattering data shows very uniform shape
and size so because of this um this is
what kind of Y ultracentrifugation is
perfect for on us to use to purify these
nanoparticles because they will all
migrated distinctly based on their
sedimentation rates and so we've also
been able to move you know very finely
control the size of these nanoparticles
based on the number of nucleotides alone
so if you see you can serve with the PRN
a through a junction and we created a
small square a medium square in a large
square all designed on a computer to
meet 2010 and 5 nanometers respectively
along the edge from large to small and
then arm based on our AFM and our GLS
data you get particles that are very
similar in size to what we're actually
design so using this method we can very
easily in generate different sizes and
different shape nanoparticles which have
some great applications on for the eve
of work and that's actually something
that we're exploring pretty attempted
right now so now I mentioned that in
vivo use of these nanoparticles well
this is actually the PRN ax motif that I
showed you earlier developed by dr.
Hawke and so they injected these
particles by tail vein injection and you
can see after four and eight hours our
PR na x particle accumulates in the
tumor and then after eight hours it
stays in the tumor and you can see no
healthy organs show any sign of
fluorescence so that's that's where
we're headed with our on a nanoparticle
technology and that's why it was so
important for me to develop these
methods for the large-scale purification
so now to start with these methods the
first step is to purify your
single-stranded RNA so following
large-scale transcription or on say one
or two and else you should get quite a
bit of RNA so rather than using page or
fplc we want to use this
ultracentrifugation to purify these
particles so the this one here is using
a cesium chloride equilibrium density
gradient so the way this works is you
basically you mix in your sample to be
medium density cesium chloride pipe it
that in and then you load your high and
your low density season chloride and
after ultracentrifugation your gradient
forms and your particles separated based
on their density so here's a somewhat
detailed of protocol like I just I just
mentioned earlier um some important
things to remember when doing things
like this um is you don't you want to
try and pipette these solutions and very
slowly um you don't want to disturb the
gradient in between each because then
that will affect how well your density
gradient forms were also interviewing
and that's the most important part
because as you like at me like i said as
your gradient forms your particles move
with the gradient so if you have a very
uniform gradient you should get a good a
good purification of your honor um so
RNA being the most dense molecule in the
solution compared to their proteins and
then so in your solution you'll have
proteins you'll have salts and you will
have our ntps from the transcription
mixture that's in get incorporated into
the RNA and then you'll have DNT PS as
well because that would be degraded by
dnace after your transcription so RNA
will be the most dense molecule any
solution
migrate to the most dense portion of the
gradient which is at the bottom so after
you do on your ultra centrifugation you
will take fractions and it depends on
the resolution you want 200 to 300
microliters is normally fine and then
what you do is you'll collect these
fashions from the top being careful to
take it from take it directly from the
top so you can keep your resolution as
high as possible and then you just you
can I have a gel announce is shown here
so you can take a quick run a quick
agarose gel or you could use you could
try to do the absorbance measurements
however your nucleotides were also
absorbed so it's best to do some type of
gel analysis with here's atheneum
bromide staining so you can see I have
some real data here at the bottom right
from purifying the PRN a monomer and you
can see that the direction of
segmentation left to right so my faction
17 was the most dense an infection one
was the least dense so you can see the
RNA migrates the nurse dense portion of
the gradient so after a sample
collection you want to combine combine
all your particles and then now a big
this is a big step or an important step
rather is to you need to remove the
season chloride from your sample because
that could affect mean for us it will
affect the salt concentration
concentration definitely affects the
assembly process and yield of assembly
for on the airport so there's there's
two there's really there's two options
you can do if you want to move the
season flight from all of your sample at
once you can you bag dialysis and um you
can dial eyes your RNA into just EDTA
buffer so trisomy to ca is a good buffer
to store your sample in because like I
mentioned earlier it chelate synagogue
mainland
metal ions that promote the cleavage of
the RNA by new faces or it's perfectly
fine if you want to store your sample
ncsu chloride for example if you want to
do a huge transcription and purification
but you only need like a little bit of
sample out of time you can freeze it in
your cesium chloride and then you can
just take Alcott's out as you need them
and perform a quick drop dialysis which
is just using a dialysis membrane and
you can take 10 to 15 microliters of
your sample and dialyze it into trisomy
MTA and then your season fried should
also be moved that way so after so I
after um after on a purification the
next step is nanoparticle assembly so
there's two different types of
nanoparticles are two different types of
formation processes that we use in our
lab the one down here on the Left would
from y'all for all the nanoparticles
made from the period junction is on what
we call a thermal denaturation and slow
cooling process so you mix all of your
strands in equal molar amount put them
in a tube then you can use a
thermocycler and you keep all of the
computer strains up so they're all
firmly the nation not base pair and then
you slowly cool it to four degrees over
about an hour and then you'll get the
formation of these nanoparticles on
another another way to do it is um this
pertains to the PRN a nano particles on
the bottom right of the slide is just
mixing of your PR na your different p
rnas and the present server magnesium of
magnesium ions and this met these
magnesium ions promote the interaction
between the left and right hand of the
particles so on after the annealing
process um is now when we actually moved
to the purification of the particles um
so as i mentioned earlier a very good
method for
to use for this is rate zonal
purification based on the uniformity of
sides and shape of our particles we're
basically trying to purify our assemble
nanoparticles from our non annealed
single shan't oligomers um like I said
earlier on it's always important to make
sure that you are using sterilized
reagents when making your super
solutions bacteria can grow in the super
solutions so it's probably best to store
your solutions at four degrees four
degrees or make them fresh each time
you're not there either and so as a
proof of this concept um i'm going to
show you guys are some some methods i
developed to purify the PRN a monomer
and diamond constructs alright so first
the first thing you need to do for the
rate zone is a gradient preparation so
this is one method to prepare your
gradient and that's by manual layering
so basically you put you on you prepare
for solutions of secrets five ten
fifteen and twenty percent weight to
volume on and this isn't 1x team s
buffer because remember our PR na
particles are their formation is
dependent on the magnesium ions on so
this is just an example of a five to
twenty if you wanting to do a five to
thirty you would want to make for evenly
spaced density gradients and then you
want it and then you want to carefully
layer it each of them into your tube
starting with the least dense so you
will put your five percent solution in
first and then you take a syringe with a
long needle and you put the needle to
the bottom of the tube and slowly a
syringe in another one point two
milliliters of your ten percent solution
and so this temperature solution will
then go to the bottom meet the fight and
then you repeat this twice with the 15
and then with the 20 this helps to keep
your resolution in between your layers
for now of
you're four different density sucrose
solutions because it's important to keep
the cutest solution separate so you need
to pipe at this slowly and you need to
take good take care when you're doing
this um and then to form the gradient
you'll actually incubate in four degrees
overnight and all your layers will
slowly merge together to form a
continuous great arm but for us in the
lab we have a automated gradient maker
so to do that all you do is you make two
different sucrose solutions for example
here we're making a five to twenty
percent gradient so we have a five
percent synchro solution and we have a
20-percent sucrose solution and then
from some for this solution for this
gradient rather you rotate it from one
minute 13 seconds at 86 degrees tilt at
16 rpms um also be different for every
gradient so if you have a gradient maker
refer to your manufacturer's protocol
for your desired creating but it will
always be it will always be in your
least dense to your most dense so for
example if you're making again the five
to thirty percent gradient you would
load in your five percent first followed
by thirty percent sucrose of two point
four milliliters of each and then follow
the protocol of an infection um so
another good option when you're running
a super stray dient is to use a sucrose
cushion so what a superstition does is
that on it prevents the pelleting of
your larger of larger particles that are
that may happen to be more dense than
you expect pelleting it can be bad for
nanoparticles because if they get too
aggregated they will they were from
artisanal finger pellet and they'll be
become aggregated and this can lead to
some degradation
of your particles so to form a sucrose
cushion on form your gradient first when
you stress that inform your gradient
first and then you take a sixty percent
sucrose solution and you can take you
take your long needle and you pipette it
to the bottom of your tube and what you
end up with is your five to twenty
percent gradient followed by a sixty
percent cushion and armed so this just
helps to prevent any pelleting of your
nano particles which is not good for
them so then the sample boating of this
is different than the season chloride
one for the season cord gradient you
were loaded your sample into the actual
gradient but for the rape zone you
actually preforming a gradient and then
load your sample on top and I have a
schematic here on the left so you larger
particles on top ten after
centrifugation you should get a
separation based on your protocol size
for example the single-stranded RNA
monomers at the top of the tube and then
the single tubes in the middle of two
followed by the work would be aggregates
of multiple cubes at the bottom so in
this case my target is actually the
single cubes so after you centrifuge you
can do agarose gel analysis and
basically what you should see is armed
and you have just your single strand RNA
oligomers they will migrate the fastest
then as you get to your cubes so your
target particle they will migrate on
slower than the single strain but slow a
lot faster than your aggregated so
basically you run a gel and then from
that gel determine which fractions are
going to collect and then on as far as
sample as far as fraction collection
goes it's the same process as the cesium
fluoride you can do dialysis or you
could even do
ethanol precipitations have to remove
most if not all of your sucrose solution
so then after this dialysis or not
precipitation step it's important it was
important for me at least for proof of
concept to verify the biological
activity of the cesium chloride or the
season chloride on purified rnase and
yeah to verify that biological activity
of the cesium chloride purified I may um
so what you see on the very left is the
difference in the structure between API
a monomer in a PRN a diamond and then in
the middle is on the is a plot of the
absorbance of the fractions firm a rate
zonal gradient purification of in black
the monomer and embedded diamond so you
can see a like I said earlier our
particles from very very high
efficiently high efficiency and made on
very distinct size so it enables us to
get our particles out from a very low
number of fractions and then on the
right is a polyacrylamide gel showing
the comparison of lanes 1 through 3
which are lanes 1 & 2 are the two
monomers a B Prime and V a prime in
carving their purified by cesium
chloride ultracentrifugation lambs three
is the dimer that is a symbol and
purified by sucrose ultracentrifugation
and then lanes 4 5 & 6 are that done has
that done that same process but done by
traditional page page gels so you can
see that we get a very calm people it's
actually identical results to page so
basically we don't lose any biological
activity and they're able to get larger
amounts from this ultra centrifugation
so just in summary atena I've kind of
talked to you guys about why I think RNA
is great
and why we need these different methods
for the large-scale production of not
only single strand on May but also the
RNA oligomers and I hope I've convinced
you that this ultra centrifugation
method can be used as a better
alternative to page or hplc um so that I
would like to thank my advisor
doctor-patient whoa and my collaborators
dr. Chad Schwartz what I would also like
to thank for moderating this webinar for
me and as I mentioned earlier dr. Farzin
hawk another collaborator that helped me
with this work and then I would also
like to thank all my other lab members
pictured here and also the University of
Kentucky and NIH funding that helped
fund this work thank you great thank you
for that highly informative presentation
Daniel before we get started on the
question and answer session I liked our
mana audience that you can still submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
at the lower left of the presentation
window we had several very good
questions come in today one listener was
asking for a method to separate
single-stranded RNA from double-stranded
RNA we talked a little bit about that
during the presentation and the listener
is interested in obtaining a percent of
single-stranded RNA in their
double-stranded RNA solution can you
give us a little insight there Daniel um
well I can definitely tell you that
using the cesium chloride on the density
method that will definitely be able to
separate the single straight from the
double-stranded the only thing I can say
is that if you're single stranded RNA
does form some type of secondary
structure to where it is a
single-stranded or it's where it acts
more like a double-stranded RNA then the
separation resolution not be that great
so you need to make sure that you knew
some type of denaturing the agent in
your sample to make sure your single
shown RNA is actually a single-stranded
um as far as a percent or I think that's
probably sample specific I'm not really
sure I can offer you an exact percent
member great thank you for that our next
question is in regards to designing
nanoparticles how does one start is this
based on a secondary structure is there
some bioinformatics involved just give
us a little bit of introduction into
designing rna-based nanoparticles okay
okay that is a that's a good question
actually so for in our lab at all it
started some natural from the period
junction nanoparticle we were trying to
have something small and compact that
could possibly be used as then we've
used as he can veto delivery parkil so
it started with investigating the
stability of the stated junction if we
could actually be used so once we
determine that it was very stable
surprisingly stable actually um
basically you are seeking to expand the
diversity on the size and the shape of
nanoparticles because
that affects its properties in vinegar
as far as circulation time accumulation
and healthy organ toxicity but i would
say it from if you're gonna start from
the ground up designing nanoparticle we
didn't use any bioinformatics you just
did some computer models and using this
recipe DVD worth to manually construct
these particles arm so i would say as a
logical way um start with some stable on
a motif Arnie motifs are very
sequence-dependent that the sequence is
the same it will fold I'm Your Honor
unless a long hunt for some time but it
will fold with very high efficiency and
it's on in this actual confirmation for
example or through a junction the way we
construct those nanoparticles it's not
the Fourier junction is not by itself
it's it's incorporating into these
external strains of the particles on you
can actually look at we have two
publications in ecs na no detailing the
construction methods but you found that
this food a junction actually drives the
formation of each particles so I would
just say you could start with a motif
some type of RNA motif and kind of go
from there to expand it and you could
really make you probably wouldn't even
need to use my teeth the base pairing of
RNA is burning fabricating yourself can
be very predictable but it also helps to
start from building block like an eye on
it like a Samana monteith park needed
with Celia junction
perfect thanks again one more question
is what is the purity of the RNA that
you can reach using ultracentrifugation
and are there any deleterious effects of
caesium chloride after purifying using
this method um I would say the theory of
the RNA is pretty high if you look at
the slide here and look you can still
see it but the the two bands in lanes 1
& 2 compared to four and five by
traditional HR they very similar to that
by page so I would say if if you think
paid purity is good enough than i would
definitely think that ultra
centrifugation purity is good enough um
and as far as cesium chloride in bebo I
can't say for certain that I assume that
it would not do good things in vivo um
so there could be some side effects but
I would just say you know do you could
be my food multiple dialysis steps or
dialyze it overnight or after you
Foreman particles dialyze it again the
dialysis should remove the season
chloride pretty easily you just may need
to do multiple steps if you want to be
one hundred percent sure that it's a
it's the out thank you unfortunately we
are out of time I want to thank the
audience for the interesting questions
and participation in today's event I'd
also like to thank our sponsor beckman
coulter and of course Daniel Jasinski
for making today's educational webcast
possible which will also be available
for on-demand viewing through beckman
coulter com thanks again goodbye